[Music]
since the pandemic The Whole World's
been thinking about how best to fight
infection
[Music]
cell types in particular have become
immunity celebrities
T cells are equipped with missiles that
they can basically fire into those cells
and Destroy them we have
to stimulate T-cell immunity
Navara antibody mediated immunity
[Music]
it's hard these days to find someone who
hasn't heard of tnv stuff I think
but it wasn't always like this
criticism came from being married who
said be empty set represent the first
and last letter of the word [ __ ]
so how did Jack
and Max solve the puzzle
the B and T cells
[Applause]
[Music]
I had two sisters
and Jacqueline contracted tuberculosis
in those days
there was no cure and she died
December 1940.
I heard the doctor tell my mother
we don't understand anything about
infectious disease no idea what happens
because we can't get all the bacteria
there wasn't a bacteria and we can't
kill any of the viruses and the viruses
are very important
to give us measles polio flu and
smallpox and a lot of other things and
uh well we can't touch them at all so I
thought that was interesting
so that that was one of the reasons I
thought maybe I'd do medicine
Jack's curiosity led him to pursue a
career in the emerging field of
Immunology
scientists knew about the existence of
antibodies
molecules that neutralize pathogens such
as viruses antibodies which prevent
germs from harming you and that there
were some immune cells called
lymphocytes
whilst it was clear that these cells
were important no one knew where they
came from what exactly they did or why
some people's immune systems could adapt
to fight disease
and others couldn't
during his early Research into a
leukemia-causing virus in mice he became
intrigued by one forgotten piece of the
puzzle an organ called the thymus
I was told that it is a
non-functional organ and was just a
graveyard for dying lymphocytes
there were some lymphocytes in the
thymus but they weren't made there and
when adult mice had their thymus removed
when they were thymectomized nothing
happened even
sir Peter medawa who had the Nobel Prize
said as late as 1963 and I quote we
shall come to regard and lymphocytes in
the Siamese as an evolutionary accident
of North very great significance
but Jacques was beginning to see some
connections between the health of his
mice and the health of the thymus the
leukemia virus starts causing
changes mutation in some time it steps
and the Samus becomes cancerous and
spreads to other disuse so that you get
leukemia
so I wanted to know more about this
organ scientists had already confirmed
that nothing much happened if a thymus
was removed from an adult
but what about if there was no thymus
from birth
Jack thought that question might help
him solve the thymus puzzle how do I
test it I take out the sadness of
Newberg mice and then wait say
four weeks and had put a new balance
back as a graft and see if these mice
get leukemia when you inject them with
Cyrus when they were about four five six
weeks old they started wasting
while I'm wasting it some of them died
and I saw they had less lymphocytes in
the circulation less lymphocyte than the
lymphoid structures like lymph nodes and
spleen than normal mice
removing the thymus did stop the mice
from developing leukemia
but the rest of their immune system
began falling apart
what was happening with the thymus why
was this organ previously believed to be
useless
so important and why was removing it
early in life making the mice sick
so I thought maybe this mice which have
been summoned but at Birth cannot induce
a proper immune response I'm not going
to test this well one way to test it was
to graft
skin
From Mice of a different strain one of a
healthy immune system's core functions
is to reject foreign objects and that
includes things like skin grafts
they should reject it normally might
reject it in 10 days
the only place I make the most never
never rejected them I had four different
graphs on these sneoglycemic Mass rice
of different colors they looked like a
patchwork print
[Music]
without a thymus something in the
juvenile's immune system had changed
and is it direct result of my work on
leukemia I discovered the function of
Alzheimer's
is educating stem cells to become
lymphocytes
educating them like a school and these
specialized lymphocytes educated in the
thymus became known as T cells
we now know that these specialized T
lymphocytes are Central to our entire
adaptive immune system
and without them Jack's young mice could
not fight off infection or learn to
recognize and reject foreign skin grafts
it was a big Discovery but there were
many questions remaining
although the thymus seemed to help the
lymphocyte specialize it didn't produce
them in the first place so where did
they come from to answer that we would
need the help of a different animal
at Ohio State University Bruce Glick had
been removing another mystery organ
called the Bursa of fabricius from
chickens as part of his research on
sexual development
but akali came by and asked for some of
his chickens to demonstrate antibody
production
he came back later with a complaint
Bruce you spoiled my experiments lots of
your chickens didn't make antibodies
the lack of antibodies in these chickens
suggested a serious Fault In Their
immune system
but Max hadn't initially thought that
the Bursa was relevant to immunity
Max recalled Jack's work and devised his
own experiment to see if he could
finally figure out the different roles
of the Bursa and the thymus in immune
cell production
I chose to use whole body of radiation
and then remove the thymus of the Bursa
or both or neither
let them grow up and recover and when
the results started coming up I burned
more adrenaline in that week than I had
burned in any year I think before in my
life the results were absolutely
clear-cut
removing the thymus did not stop
antibody production but removing the
Bursa did
the bursa's job was to make lymphocytes
some of which go for training at the
immune School in the thymus becoming T
cells and some of which remain in the
blood as B cells producing antibodies
if you remove the thymus you destroy the
immune School stopping lymphocytes from
becoming T cells and learning how to
fight infection
the B cells are still produced without a
thymus but become much less effective
without their specialized T Cell
colleagues to help them
it was the first proof that there were
two different types of adaptive immune
cells and understanding how B and T
cells work together to fight diseases
would be the launch of some of the most
vital advances of the biomedical
Sciences
that idea that there were two lineages
of cells changed everything we were
thinking about at that point in
Immunology
it meant that we had to find out how T
cells helped B cells and to do their
antibody responses in an optimal way
how does this affect the development of
immunodeficiency diseases
where is a bursa equivalent in mammals
like us and the Bursa equivalent in
humans the place where these cells were
being produced would turn out to be the
bone marrow B fits both Bursa and bone
marrow the teeth its thymus derive
so what what's going on
obviously there must have been a
collaboration between T cells and bone
marrow derived cell called B cells
but people didn't like that why didn't
they like that they said they circulate
in the blood and in the lymph how would
they ever find each other it's not the
logical
but of course we didn't know at the time
that cells produce what we call
lymphocytes or cytokines which are kind
of messages to talk to each other
knowing where these cells were trained
and that they collaborated to give us
adaptive immunity was the first step in
understanding how we might tweak the
immune response ourselves
scientists could start to tackle
diseases from two new angles even giving
us ways to fight viruses that no human
had experienced before
it's getting almost everybody's
attention these days with a covered
pandemic for example
antibodies disappear after a certain
time but she said see the inside of the
virus it translates into new ways of
treating cancers it translates into
leukemias and other kinds of
malignancies autoimmune disease
immunodeficiency disease even pregnancy
even wound repair T cells have a role
it's hard to imagine modern science
without the brilliant B and T cells and
the most exciting part is what we might
be able to do with them next as future
developments and advances offer further
and deeper understanding that may
revolutionize the treatment of disease
Jacques Miller may be the last person to
discover the function of a human organ
but there are many other puzzles to be
solved in understanding ourselves our
bodies and what keeps us healthy if we
just stay curious enough people think
I'm dead I mean I'm 91 years old
so I should be dead by statistics when
they talk about tnb cells I have no idea
that these cells were discovered in last
century
they had no idea the same with the
assignments it's a very it's
sophisticated organ it's only been there
since 1961.
[Music]